[Music]
[Applause]
albert brier senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist the monday morning
quarterback i don't there's no better
you know easier way to segue in uh
albert unless you have something on
kanye west and pete davis no i mean like
i'm so out of the loop with kanye west i
remember i think this is a basketball
game um a couple months ago there were
pictures of antonio brown that came up
and kanye had that mask over him or
whatever like where it was just like
looked like i don't know he looked at
that mime or something you know
and like immediately everybody's like oh
abs with kanye i'm like how do you know
that's kanye so like i'm really really
out of the loop with kanye west but
that's a hell of a comeback from pete
davidson i don't know how you respond to
that one but also didn't ab and kanye
express the interest in buying the
denver broncos
yeah yeah i guess so i mean we'll see
how that goes for him i'm not sure that
uh i'm not sure that's going to work if
i'm kanye i don't attach antonio brown
to the po probably not but probably not
the way to go like you might john elway
peyton manning you might want to get
those people in on it and on it as
investors you know
antonio brown maybe not
more surprised tom brady unretired or
that he retired in the first place
um
i would say more surprised that he'd
retired in the first place and you know
i i really think dan like
now like kind of like getting a global
look at this
um
you know i think either he was forced
into making a decision
back in january or he wanted it to look
forced to buy himself more time does
that make sense yeah like either the
news came coming out when adam and jeff
had it right
forced him to sort of push that thing
along faster than he wanted to push it
along
or
and that's just a conspiracy theory of
mine he wanted it to look forced he
wanted it to look like he was pushed
into it so people would leave him alone
for five or six weeks and then he could
actually sort of let the rest of it play
out
so
you know like that number 45 has been a
magic number him for him for a while
it's not an arbitrary number it's a
number he and tom house's throwing coach
had come up with a long time ago because
that's how long nolan ryan pitched and
he believed he could make it to 45.
i don't think his love for football has
waned i don't think that he thinks that
he's lost much off his fastball
um now i think as much as anything else
dan this came down to where he was going
to play
what team he was going to play for in
2022
but i don't know that like he ever fully
detached from the idea of playing even
when he announced his retirement and
like
he left breadcrumbs all over the
freaking place i mean it was like what
five days after he announced his
retirement that he's telling jim gray uh
who knows you know what i mean like
you never say never yeah and that's not
the things those aren't the things you
say
if you've really kind of come to peace
with the idea that you're walking away
from football but you think it's just
tampa that that there's no chance that
he's
because they're making moves now that
they might not have made if blaine gavin
was going to be the quarterback here you
think that if tom's playing its tampa
and no chance with the 49ers i mean i
think that he had an interest in the
49ers i also think the 49ers you know
had an interest in him
um i think maybe this is more with him
coming to peace with the fact that the
bucks
weren't going to let him go anywhere you
know and that doesn't mean he didn't
want to play for the bucks but
you know i think like i think the timing
of this you know obviously is to set up
at the beginning of the league year the
bucks have a boatload of free agents now
they took care of ryan jensen last night
but that's just the start i mean alex
kappa jason pierre-paul rob gronkowski
carlton davis
you can go right on down the line
leonard fournette there are a ton of
guys
that are free agents in dama consu
so you know i think brady knew that if
he was going to make a decision and if
the bucks were going to hold him to his
contract
and his option to play in 2022 was going
to be in tampa and nowhere else
he had to make this decision now so
some of those free agents
would know the landscape and then maybe
make the decision to come back based on
the fact that he's there whereas if he's
not there and you're say like an alex
kappa or a carlton davis or one of these
guys who's looking for his first real
big payday as an nfl player
you're probably just going to go to the
highest bidder
we're talking albert breer you can read
the monday morning quarterback he's a
senior nfl reporter deshaun watson with
what happened on friday
and then what could happen tomorrow
uh what's his future
immediate future or this season in the
nfl i think like from the league
standpoint we still don't have full
clarity on that because they still could
levy a suspension now you know i've
heard the argument is that time served
you know he spent a year not playing um
you know he was paid during that year so
like i think that there is a little bit
of gray area there
but i do think that there's a a good
amount of teams that are comfortable
with where this is right now after the
grand jury made its decision
um not to move forward with with
criminal charges
um and i can tell you this too dan
there are a handful of teams i mean
every team that's had an interest in him
right has had its security people on
this and those security people for
people don't know that's ex-law
enforcement that these teams employ
those people have been following this
for the last year so it's not like teams
just started doing homework i'm also
told that a smaller number of teams had
private investigators they employed on
the ground in houston over the last year
so there are a couple teams there
that are hitting the ground running now
that know everything about this case and
that are well aware
of where the civil cases stand
they have their own opinions on how all
that went down
and i mean i think you can see with the
aggression of teams like the saints and
the panthers
that
like not only is this you know
not only is that interest there because
he's a 26 year old franchise quarterback
who led the league in passing in 2022 or
in 2020 who is under contract for the
next four years which is about as
valuable commodities
as there is in in in pro football
they've also come to a comfort level
with the off-field stuff and that's not
to minimize any of the stuff that desean
was accused of but there are a lot of
teams that have done a lot of homework
on this and and i think you can see
which ones are in a good place as far as
you know having their owners which is an
important piece of this on board with
making a run at deshaun watts but is
this one fell swoop a big big check that
he's going to have to write
for these women assuming i think there's
yeah i mean i i think that there's a
chance that happens now you know my
understanding was a while back there was
like you know an affordable settlement
offer made to deshaun watson that he
walked away from at one point i know
he had resolved to
you know you know let these things play
out and try to prove his innocence
now like
do i think he's still thinking that way
when he's so close to going to a new
team when maybe that new team says
before we trade for you we need you to
settle all of your your your your
lawsuits yeah i think it's possible that
you know that
however our trade goes down it leads to
the settlement of these lawsuits um
because you know i think desean watson
probably wants to move on right now
um you know but like i think there have
been opportunities to do that to settle
all of these over the last year and
watson has been resistant to that so i
don't know that it's a slam dunk that he
necessarily does it i think if it makes
sense for him and helps him move on from
a football standpoint maybe he would
what
saints panthers are they at the
head of the class here for desean watson
anybody else you throw in there saints
panthers cleveland
i've been mentioning them for like for a
year on the show i know i really think
cleveland
wants to take a swing here because if
you look at their roster again a lot of
guys in the the heart of the prime of
their careers um i think philly you know
i think philly is another team that that
everybody should just at least keep an
eye on
seattle they take a swing um the
panthers i think have been you know
clearly the most aggressive team over
the last year they made an offer to the
texans um before the before the lawsuits
were filed last year so they were
involved before all that
um you know and then the saints you know
even when sean payton was there
they were at least sniffing around and
keeping an eye on it so those are the
five teams that sort of stick out to me
and you know i think the other the other
interesting thing about this is you know
texans gm nick casario took a lot of
slings and arrows for not trading him
you know in march and in april and then
again in the summer and then again
before the trade deadline
it looks like being patient and letting
this thing play out could pay off in a
spectacular way for casario um you know
last year before the lawsuits were filed
i can tell you this dan
at one point like like i know he had you
know offers of three first-round picks
now at that point he was resolved to
keeping watson on his roster right the
lawsuits made him you know soften his
stance on that but the fact that he
could get back to where
the t the texans were you know from a
capital standpoint
um
in january and february of last year
when they were unwilling to trade for
him i think shows you that the the
patience that serious showed over the
course the last year probably is about
to pay off
davonte adams says he's not going to
play for the franchise tech in green bay
i do we still don't know the the real
structure of aaron rodgers contract here
um
i i don't know if that factors in
if
aaron is able to structure a deal that
is going to include devante adams as
yeah you know a guy more than just on a
franchise tag
yeah i think it's like there's only so
much you can do from a contractual
standpoint to create space and i think
aaron rodgers will do as much as he can
um whenever that new contract is signed
we'll do as much as he can to create
space for the package doesn't mean he's
gonna take less cash but
um you know like i i think he'll do as
much as he can and the packers are gonna
do what the buccaneers did um over the
last couple of years and mortgaging
deals put tacking phony years on the
back of contracts
and creating like a two to three year
window in which they can win and so i
think they're going to be able to create
the sort of space they're going to need
to do devonte adams what's tricky about
devonte adams contract this is a little
bit like back in the day when calvin
johnson's contract was a real outlier
there's a contract out there that's a
real outlier at receiver now too and
that's the one that deandre hopkins did
in arizona which on paper is a 27
million dollar per year deal but if you
look at the structure of it it isn't
really that so the question is you know
does devonte adams look more at where
the market has been which is around 20
21 22 million dollars and he's okay with
that or
is he shooting to get where hopkins got
and
i think you know
i think you know over time cooler heads
will prevail and you know they'll find a
middle ground and devonte adams will get
taken care of because he's so important
to aaron rodgers but this is a more
complicated negotiation than i think a
lot of people realize because there is
that big outlier contract at that
position
if there's a
business of football hall of fame kirk
cousins is the first ballot remember
that uh darrell rivas would be in there
as well kirk cousins don't forget chase
daniel oh yeah kirk kirk cousins has a
500 record as a quarterback in the nfl
he's 59 59 in two
he's made
231 million
with very little to show for
as far as playoffs big-time victories
there
what it felt like the vikings were stuck
here you got a new new coach and a new
gm but you're sticking with kirk cousins
why well and that's well i mean for one
thing let's let's start here i mean
i mean i think anybody who's been part
of a contract negotiation had a contract
negotiated for them i've been there i
know you've been there dan knows like
it's really about leverage not how good
you are you know in almost all contract
negotiations that's where it is now how
good you are is part of it you know but
that that that's only works to create
leverage
and so like you know i kirk is unique in
that he was willing to play on
consecutive franchise tax that made him
a free agent quarterbacks never become
free agents that's why he is where he is
here's what i would say about the
vikings decision making on it why i
don't hate it guys like patrick mahomes
and josh allen don't fall out of the sky
and
like would we have cr would we have
criticized andy reed nine years ago in
the current environment for trading for
alex smith when he got to kansas city
andy reid that year looked at the draft
right and saw ej manuel and geno smith
and matt barkley and said you know what
the hell with that like let's go get an
established guy so we can compete right
away
and alex smith was his quarterback there
for five years you know what alex smith
did alex smith bought him time to find
patrick mahomes and it bought him time
to build it up so when they went and
found the guy that they really loved
stuck their neck out to go get him that
guy was entering into a situation that
was already built up and ready to go
and that's what what i think the vikings
are doing with kirk cousins it's
we have a quarterback we can win with
now the head coach kevin o'connell
worked with him in washington
and we can continue to build the team up
and we can be patient
and wait for the guy that we really love
at quarterback
and win with kirk in the time being and
then whenever we find that guy down the
line
if we can go get him we'll be able to
put him in a situation that's already
built up around him and so i think the
kansas city example
both with like minnesota and kirk
cousins like vegas and derek carr
i think the kansas how kansas city did
it with alex smith can be instructive to
everybody because it shows
you can do you can serve both masters
you can get good
at the position and stay good at the
position and use it as a vehicle to
eventually become great
albert great to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us have a great week
thanks dan i appreciate it that's albert
breer senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist
the monday morning quarterback